жиза кілька днів після заяву просто
рівня в Україні нові партії ідеологом
ніякого стану Михайло Саакашвілі
будинок здивую одеській обладміністрації
прийшло власне що це пересічний цирк
тут
рахунок відповідь збувається генпрокуратура
михай тут робите ви puppey якщо ви
їдьте про право чаду незаконного в
skoda вания пдв кілька руки в тому
у пшик і каже проводив до вищого
консула грузії в Україні, а нині по
заштатного проте саакашвілі
таймураза нижня нитка за вдома та в
кабінеті 1 cтильний коду заповнюючи
зовні вони заводили адміністрації
а вже називаючи політичну
провокацію так навпаки вони пшонка вони
прокуратура путіна і первинно коріє я
вже давно так не процес геть і гейтс
розуму з'їхав і
краді і ви вирішили ще нас можна з
компромату вата та соляка ти звучиш на
повільних методами політичних
опонентів саакашвілі в Україні джемала
його поєдинку часто з прямо тяг популізм
в одну годину номера навчальні колоди та
складу взята доля вуст вороні нові
партії та карбідна демократичні сили
експерти скептично оцінили від шов
деконструкції
заявляється саакашвілі вин починати ахнуть
і copter на себе зрозуміло та вин буде
залишатися фігуру та номер один top to
win буде домину вати над ним активістів
в 1 годину а гаманець і завищується крем на
кому в розинському парку єдиний
національний рук на пари до низу і ви
про номер брат і доля опери 2 барні
компанії до грузинського парламенту тем
експерти відбилися з означає повертай на
політичну арену екс-президента грузії
буду непростим вона ж їх усі і вій
партії за раз надати все-таки прийти до
у влади в грузії буде і дуже багата
противники саакашвілі та йому наївність
основу статті залі національної
президентом експерти на коня зміни
тягнуся у грузії zara саакашвілі буду не
просто цьому скаже перспектив для нього
batch від самого україни дано апсиді
радикальної реформи і хоча саакашвілі на
думку багатьох полі точних iq спортивні
волоком домкратом
свого годинника грудей even проявивши себе і
дах че реформатор у team of ряду чини
pm нині
ще його жорсткі методи управління
запитати в Україні